nous vous écoutons monsieur le premier
ministre au moment particulier est grave
ou un parti extrémiste vient d'arriver
en tête d'une élection nationale
encore avant nous la chance si l'on peut
dire en france où l'on apprend dès
l'école à révérer robespierre qu'à la
différence des autres pays où le
populisme et seulement d'extrême droite
il est chez nous partager en deux rangs
dans les chiffres en apparence moins
alarmant mais en apparence seulement
ce qui est incompréhensible c'est que
pour réclamer plus de démocratie des
électeurs votent pour le parti recorman
du népotisme et de l'opacité dirigé
depuis 50 ans par le père puis la fille
puis bientôt la nièce pour dénoncer un
système qu'ils estiment corrompus ils
votent pour le parti recorman des rendez
vous judiciaires et que pour redresser
l'économie ils votent pour une
dirigeante qui a fait la preuve de son
incompétence absolu en la matière lors
de la présidentielle
napoléon disait en politique une
absurdité n'est pas un obstacle
nous le constatons tous les jours
si les partis extrêmes ne représente
plus que 30 % aujourd'hui ce qui est
tout de même considérable contre 40% il
y a deux ans c'est grâce à
l'effondrement du lider minimo de la
france soumise à cuba le corps sacré
auto claironné lors d'une perquisition
par l'homme au micro entre les dents la
disqualifier jusque chez ses proches
les casquettes d'exclusion ont délié les
langues et nous savons maintenant
comment avec son égérie de diriger leur
groupuscule après la défaite les jeunes
loups du parti estiment que leur tour
est venu du remue ménage en perspective
quand on sait que plusieurs d'entre eux
sont le genre de personne qui entre
derrière vous dans une porte à tambour
et qui en ressortent les premiers et
malgré cela ce qui est incroyable ce
n'est pas que les filles soient passés
de 20 % à 6 %
mais qui lit encore en 2010 9 6 % des
français qui votent pour la révolution
bolivarienne
le deuxième coup de tonnerre de cette
élection et que la gauche démocratique
et la droite républicaine à la tête du
pays pendant 60 ans et obtenu ensemble
moins de 15% des vous en ce qui concerne
le ps l'explication qui risque de ne pas
plaire et je m'en excuse me semble
largement partagé françois hollande a
mené avec constance une politique qui
ressemble à celle d'une enseigne que
j'ai vu l'autre jour sur la route
restaurant ouvrier cuisine bourgeoise
de l'autre côté nicolas sarkozy déclaré
le 26 mai dernier à 20h30
il n'y a plus de droite dans notre pays
je trouve le jugement expéditif nous
avons tous qu'il est rare qu'on meurt en
politique comme le dit un proverbe
cambodgien quand l'eau monte les
poissons mangent les fourmis quand l'eau
descend les fourmis mangent les poissons
je ne crois pas que la droite soit morte
mais elle est partie elle a commencé à
partir le jour où quelques-uns de ses
dirigeants ont décidé que la reconquête
passer par l'adoption des idées les plus
raides et qu'ils ont cessé de tenir
compte des minoritaires le parti mon
parti ne pouvait alors que s'effeuiller
comme un artichaut une feuille à la
défaite de 2012 une feuille au match de
boxe copé fillon une feuille lors du
refus de choisir entre le pen et macron
au deuxième tour de la présidentielle
une feuille aux européennes une fois la
dernière feuille parti le 26 mai au soir
la droite s'est aperçu qu'un million de
ses électeurs n'avaient pas voter pour
son candidat mais pour celles dans
marche et 500 milles pour le front
national
pendant toute la campagne les
adversaires des manuels macro l'ont
accusé de prendre l'élection en otage en
réduisant son enjeu un affrontement
entre progressistes et populiste il
n'avait pas tort mais ce qu'il n'avait
pas compris c'est que ce n'était pas
seulement un slogan de campagne
c'était aussi une réalité lorsque
presque tous les pays de l'est de
l'europe plus l'italie sont dirigés par
des populistes lorsqu'ils font 15 à 30%
partout en europe de l'ouest
lorsqu'on est entouré de poutine der de
haine ou de cleaning ping il est temps
pour les démocrates d'affronter les
populistes et non de leur courir après
le monde est devenue dangereuse
le monde est devenu dangereux et
compliquée avant vous étiez de gauche du
centre ou de droite et vous votiez en
conséquence cette grille contrairement à
ce qu'on dit n'a pas été remplacé par
l'opposition démocrate populiste mais il
ya désormais deux axes de lecture l'axé
gauche-droite et lax démocrate populiste
je partage l'analyse du président sur ce
point mais je préfère de loin le terme
de démocrates à celui de progressistes
temps j'ai vu dans ma vie se produire de
catastrophes au nom du progrès la 10e
alice renaissance est arrivé 2e le 26
mai mais vous êtes presque le seul à
l'avoir fait remarquer monsieur le
premier ministre
sa déroute était tellement près dit que
le reste du monde semble persuadée
qu'elle a gagné je suppose que vous ne
vous en plaignez pas mais si j'insiste
sur ce point c'est qui me paraît
important que quelqu'un et vous n'êtes
pas n'importe qui garde la tête froide
depuis quinze jours certains cris de
victoire un peu bruyant certaines
injonctions un peu appuyé certains
appellent un peu martiaux ne sont
peut-être pas la meilleure façon de
préparer l'avenir et de rassembler
vous
vous rester lucide et c'est à saluer
l'acte 1 du quinquennat a permis des
réformes importantes la sncf le code du
travail l'école de la confiance et
d'autres la majorité du sénat les a
souvent soutenu souvent amende est aussi
l'acteur a aussi été marquée par une
grave crise sociale parce que la
disruption on peut trouver ça sympa mais
ça n'est pas toujours la vie de ceux qui
sont disrupt et vous êtes venus
aujourd'hui nous annoncer l'acte de 8,6
même il y a deux mois je disais la
conclusion du grand débat c'est un peu
une lettre au père noël
le président a promis d'en tenir compte
et c'est heureux mais il va falloir
aussi pour une part qui lui résiste
c'est la raison pour laquelle la phrase
la plus importante de votre discours à
mes yeux c'est constance et cohérence
dans l'action
elle va susciter deux sortes de
réactions ceux qui diront que vous
n'avez rien entendu qu'il faut d'urgence
faire marche arrière et les autres c'est
mon cas qui vous diront que c'est en
restant immobile qu'on fait le plus de
faux pas vous nous annoncez une société
de la confiance et de la justice lever
les freins à l'emploi libérer les
énergies renforcer les collectivités
territoriales et décentralisé faciliter
la mobilité sociale renforcer l'égalité
entre les territoires qu'ils soient
métropolitain ou ultramarins redéfinir
le périmètre de l'état et vous avez
commencé par cela tout faire pour
laisser à nos enfants une planète
vivable
il n'y a rien dans tout cela qu'ils ne
puissent être approuvée mais qui doit
l'être avec vigilance car au delà de ce
que vous nous avez dit il y a deux ou
trois choses que nous aurions aimé
entendent ou tout au moins entendre plus
précisément des assurances chiffre est
sûre le nom dérapage des finances
publiques dans la mise en oeuvre de ces
réformes
des précisions sur le mécano fiscales
qui ne nous semble pas abouti et qui ne
nous rend pas certain que vous arriverez
deux siècles après à faire mentir
l'adage de benjamin franklin
il n'y a que deux chose certaine dans la
vie la mort et les impôts
quant à la baisse quant à la baisse des
effectifs de la fonction publique
elle ne semble plus si urgent ce qui
nous fait craindre que l'administration
continue d'être ce qui se rapproche le
plus de la vie éternelle
la réforme constitutionnelle repose
avant tout sur les engagements
réciproques et la loyauté de trois
personnes qui avaient beaucoup travaillé
et beaucoup échangé le président de la
république le président du sénat le
premier ministre vous le savez je suis
de ceux qui pensent que ces engagements
auraient été tenus après avoir mobilisé
beaucoup d'énergie elle semble devoir
rester un certain temps dans le cloud
comme on dit aujourd'hui je lui laisse
donc nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler
lorsqu elle redescendra du ciel je
premier ministre notre groupe très
majoritairement approuvera votre
discours de politique générale